- OK, running back committee, help yourselves to some pastries.
- [Speaking over each other:] FEED ME. FEED ME.
- I’m not hungry right now.
- I’M SO FED, I’M GOING TO YAC.
That’s a yards-after-catch joke.
- Our Q3 numbers are strong, but QBs are trending towards throwing the ball in Q4.
- Ah, interesting.
- Curious.
- I hate it when they throw.
- I’M MY WHOLE TEAM NOW.
- Settle down. You’re acting like real receivers.
- IT’S NOT THAT HARD:
THROW THE BALL WELL ENOUGH TO CATCH BUT BAD ENOUGH THAT WE LOOK COOL.
- Yo, what do I pay the pizza guy, like a million?
- And this is why holding out works.
I made less money, and now I play for the Jets.
- Cool.
- Thanks for sharing.
- WHO NEEDS CONTRACTS? JUST PLAY FOR 40 YEARS.
- The chair recognizes the Niners subcommittee.
- [In unison:] Deep dive. Circle back. Synergy.
- Next order of business: How is Chubb growing?
- Uhh...
- HOW DARE THE HATERS SAY WE %@!#&!$ SUCK JUST BECAUSE WE %@!#&!$ SUCK.
- Maybe I’m the star.
Fine.
- Rapid-fire ideas to increase value: Go.
- WE NEED QBS THAT DON’T DO WHAT WE DO.
- NOSE PIERCINGS, ARM TAPES, AIRHEADS.
- FOUR P.M. SHOULD BE DINNER TIME, NOT GAME TIME.
- All right, gentlemen, meeting adjourned.
- WHY DOES HE GET MORE PIZZA THAN ME?
- IT’S THE SAME AMOUNT OF PIZZA. I JUST DO MORE WITH IT!
- I'm Eli, and lately I've had some time to learn about the internet.
You can subscribe below, whatever that means.
Here let me type in Eli Manni—
Oh, no....